now that we've seen how to describe a
rotating vector we can use that to
analyze the motion of our gyroscope so
again I'll draw a side view of my pivot
my rod here's the wheel I'll call this
point s that's a distance D and we'll
assume that the angular velocity is in
that direction so that the spin angular
velocity vector is pointing outwards in
the plus R hat direction
that's the K hat direction and theta hat
is into the screen now again the weight
is acting downwards at the center fast
at the wheel there's a normal force
acting upwards so the spin angular
momentum with respect to point s is just
equal to the moment of inertia of the
disc about its center of mass times the
angular speed of the spin and that's
directed in the plus R hat direction and
this is the angular momentum with
respect to point s now the torque with
respect to point s again it's R cross F
relative to point s that's going to be M
G D in the plus theta hat direction and
for a fast Omega of Omega is a large
angular speed and therefore if the
angular momentum vector is a large
vector then the torque which acts
perpendicular to the angular momentum
will cause the angular momentum vector
to rotate and so as a rotating vector we
can write that
the magnitude of the time derivative of
that rotating vector is equal to the
angular velocity of the rotation times
the length of that vector okay so the
angular and this is LS and so the length
of that vector is just I times and Omega
and then we multiply that by capital
Omega
okay now this quantity here DL DT is the
torque so that's the magnitude of the
torque but the torque we said is equal
to mg D in the theta hat direction and
so the torque and G D is equal to I
little Omega times big Omega so I can
solve for big Omega and big Omega which
is the angular speed of rotation of the
angular momentum vector is M G D divided
by the moment of inertia I times little
Omega
now recall little Omega is the angular
velocity angular speed of the spin of
the disk with a wheel capital Omega is
the angular speed of the rotation of the
angular momentum vector it basically
tells us the speed at which the center
of mass of the wheel orbits around the
vertical axis through the pivot we call
capital Omega the processional angular
velocity so the processional angular
velocity is capital Omega and notice
that the faster little Omega is
Omega is the slower the precession
angular velocity is now this expression
tells us what the magnitude of capital
Omega is what the what the magnitude of
that processional angular velocity is
but it doesn't tell us which way the
system is processing whether say viewed
from the top the motion is clockwise or
counterclockwise or equivalently which
way the vector capital Omega is pointed
we know it must point along the vertical
axis but dissapoint upwards in the plus
K hat direction or downwards in the
minus K hat direction to see that we
need to look at which way the angular
momentum vector is rotating and there
are two possibilities so let's again go
to a top view of our dire scope
so suppose here's the pivot point and
here's my gyroscope and the way I'm
drawing things is that our hat is this
way this is a top view so theta hat is
that way and K hat is out of the screen
so in the example that I did earlier the
angular momentum was pointing in the
plus R hat direction okay so that's LS
pointing that way if the torque is
pointing in the theta hat direction then
that's going to act to rotate the
angular momentum vector this way
okay and so the sense of rotation will
be like that it's in that case looking
down on the system we would see a
counterclockwise rotation and that's
equivalent to a Omega vector pointing in
the plus K hat direction
alternatively suppose the wheel were
spinning in the other direction okay so
the sense of rotation of this wheel
around the axle were in the opposite
direction in that case even when the
wheel was on this side of the pivot
again this is a top view the angular
momentum vector would be pointing in the
opposite direction so now this is my
angular momentum vector it's pointing in
the opposite direction that the axle was
pointing still along a line but in the
minus R hat direction but the torque
would still be in the theta hat
direction and so my new angular momentum
vector would rotate this way which would
be equivalent to the axle rotating in
this direction and that's equivalent to
rotation in the opposite sense clockwise
as viewed downward from the top or in
other words with capital Omega vector
pointing in the minus K hat direction so
the direction of precession depends upon
which way the wheels spinning which way
the spin angular momentum vector is
actually pointing now I just have to
point out that there's an approximation
that we've been making here I've alluded
to it but I want to make it very
specific right now we are been assuming
that the spin angular momentum vector L
is large enough that the torque vector
which is perpendicular provides only a
small angular impulse that rotates L
without changing it in length okay now
as L rotates the direction of art' hat
and the direction of theta rotate with
it and the torque is always in the theta
hat direction
so after any small delta T when the
angular momentum vector rotates the
instantaneous torque of that
next instant is still perpendicular to
the rotating angler momentum vector and
so we are making an approximation that L
is large enough that we can consider the
instantaneous angular impulse as a small
perpendicular perturbation that's
equivalent it turns out to saying that
so this is the approximation that we're
making that we've been making so far in
this lecture is that little Omega the
spin angular velocity is much much
larger than capital Omega the precession
angular velocity okay this is called the
gyroscopic approximation
we'll see a more precise statement of it
later on but it's basically equivalent
to saying that the spin angular momentum
vector is so large that we can consider
the angular impulse due to the torque as
causing a pure rotation of the vector
without any change in its length it's
important to keep in mind that a vector
can include both a rotating component
and a constant component and in that
case it's important to identify what the
rotating component is in order to use
the analysis that we presented earlier
so for example let's consider the case
of a tilted gyroscope instead of one
that's horizontal and parallel to the
ground so here's my pivot point that's
the vertical and instead of a horizontal
gyroscope now I'll draw my gyroscope at
some angle like this here's my wheel
I'll call that angle with the vertical
fee this distance is still D and I'll
use the usual coordinate system that our
hat is pointing outward this way K hat
is pointing vertically
and theta hat is pointing into the
screen now in this case the gyroscope
will still process around the vertical
axis to the pivot point and the angle
fee will remain constant now the angular
momentum vector due to spin points now
not in the r hat direction but again
outward along the axis of rotation and
that angular momentum vector can be
decomposed into two components an r hat
component and a k hat component so in
other words my angular momentum vector
can be written as the sum of a vector
pointing along the z axis or the K hat
direction plus a vector pointing in the
radial direction I can also write that
as L sub Z times K hat plus L sub R
times R hat now notice as this gyroscope
processes around the z hat component is
constant but the R hat component rotates
around okay so the R hat component they
are the the vector along the R hat
direction is a purely rotating vector
whereas the z component is a constant
vector
okay so LZ is constant and LR
is rotating and so now the magnitude of
DL DT which is equal to the magnitude of
DL z dt plus dl r DT well dl z dt since
that's a constant vector it's just 0
so the time derivative just involves the
r component and so that's equal to the
angular speed of rotation times the
length of the rotating vector which is
just the r component not the z component
so this is multiplied by L sub R now in
this particular case the r component of
the angular momentum vector is LD a
momentum vector times the sine of feet
so in this particular case this would be
omega times the full L times the sine of
feet so in the case that we have here
the angular momentum vector consists of
a constant part and a rotating part and
the magnitude of its time derivative is
equal to the angular velocity of
rotation times the length of the
rotating part of the vector